something that
we got to figure out
and we really don't have that much time
left because it's coming up bro yeah the
wedding's
bachelor party surprise you don't even
know we're gonna have like a hundred
hookers there's no i don't even know
it's just like a small one
the odds of a stripper being hotter than
thyes
is slim to none
so why would i want something not as hot
as something i got in front of me
sometimes when i go to you know the
grocery store i get rocky road sometimes
i get mint chocolate chip
you know what i'm saying
flavors
hello you what you guys can do is like
you guys can
really
i was listening okay over there you need
to take care of your life what are you
talking about
i was listening
what did i say
[Music]
what did i say
you know
i don't know you need to take care of
your life i don't know i forgot don't
say nothing nothing about what nothing
nothing that's what not to say i just
say nothing
john was talking about bachelor party
because that's what big brothers do they
they play
what are you doing bro
tell me guys
i'm gonna fire this is my favorite
husband yeah
it's not for someone that i wanted it's
not
i think
bachelor party is rigid because
i told pastor all the time if patrick
have bachelor party i will kill him and
get back to brazil that's it
[Music]